et tout de suite on retrouve l'invité
politique de la matinale ce matin avec
nous olivier marleix ex-député les
républicains d'eure et loir olivier
marleix qs en liaison avec nous par
téléphone bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france alors l'état d'urgence sanitaire
prolongé jusqu'au 1er juin ce malgré les
oppositions comme celle de la france
insoumise on regarde vous réagissez vote
liberticide numéro 4324 état d'urgence
sanitaire prolongée jusqu'à juin pleins
pouvoirs donnés à l'exécutif et
piétinement de la démocratie sanitaire
invs est liberticide selon vous folie
démarre l'ex oui et oui on avec
rencontre nous avons une nouvelle fois
aussi voté contre contre ce texte encore
au début la ville peut comprendre que le
palm en avait besoin
je donne du temps quand gérer cette
crise aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui faute à des rendez-vous plus
régulier dans le parlement surtout ça
que nous le dénonçons pour pouvoir
contrôler beaucoup plus permanent du
parlement sur l'action sur l'action du
gouvernement
là le ps en haïti prévoit de prolonger
l'état d'urgence jusqu'au premier choix
mais en réalité il permet au
gouvernement aussi de prendre des
mesures dites de sortie de l'état
d'urgence jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2021
et de gouvernement ouvrent des tunnels
dans lesquels il veut faire ce qu'il
veut alors que le parlement est tout à
fait capable s'il faut prolonger les
mesures de destineer et de voter une
nouvelle loi de bon on aurait préféré
c'est ce qu'ils n'avaient raté qui est
un rendez vous chaque mois devant le
parlement pour savoir si oui ou non des
mesures sont encore nécessaires et
quelles sont ces mesures pouvoir en
débattre ce cas de décès scandaleuse
jeudi que le gouvernement d'un côté
réunissait 35 citoyens tirés au sort
pour l'accompagner sur la stratégie
vaccinale et en même temps ils
s'assoient sur la représentation
démocratique du pays c'est tout à fait
scandaleux
alors avec la crise sanitaire gagnons
les élections régionales et
départementales repoussée
au mois de juin c'était nécessaire pour
vous alors si elle se repoussaient
uniquement jusqu'au mois de juin
oui c'était probablement nécessaire
puisque un peu compliqué d'organiser
dans matin on a des contraintes en ce
moment encore très forte des élections
pour qu'on se donne deux trois mois de
plus pour faire campagne pour permettre
de candidats de faire campagne pour la
démocratie s'est exercée pourquoi pas
cette gênante si nous ce qui me gène et
ce qui nous pose problème dans ce texte
c'est que le gouvernement s'est arrogé
une espèce de clause de revoyure début
avril qui pourrait lui permettre de des
journées encore les élections et on ne
s'est pas fait mystère l'intention du
président de la république sait s'il le
peut de se dispenser purement et
simplement d'organiser le scrutin
régional dont il sait qu'il ne lui sera
pas favorable avant les élections
présidentielles on est le seul pays où
le gouvernement se permet là encore de
jouer comme ça avec la démocratie avec
avec les élections fait des élections
une perte de quelque chose qu'il
organiserait en touchant des convenances
personnelles
autour de nous les etats unis ont été
capables d'organiser l'élection
présidentielle des portugais encore plus
proche à organiser une élection
présidentielle les pays-bas organise les
élections
tout le monde est capable de guider
élections sauf la france donc c'est
vraiment un aveu d'incapacité du
gouvernement sur la table chimiste dans
la réalité c'est que le gouvernement ou
encore mad men la démocratie alors
projet de loi présenté aujourd'hui celui
du climat et résilience années de la
convention citoyenne présenté ce matin
en conseil des ministres une lettre
ouverte signée par plus d'une centaine
d'organisations de défense des non sur
le manque d'ambition du projet regarder
alors que les propositions des citoyens
devaient être retranscrit dans la loi
force est de constater que le compte n'y
est pas et il manque d'ambition selon
vous à ce texte
on va écouter je pense que comme que
nous présente le goût le gouvernement
c'est d'abord un exercice de
communication de
on est en train de débattre si ces jours
ci d'un texte sur un autre sujet qui est
la question de la lutte contre le
radicalisme islamiste pour là aussi le
gouvernement devrait avancer le texte le
texte du siècle par le texte le plus
important du quinquennat nous avait dit
l'exécutif
en réalité ce texte est totalement creux
a pas une ou deux petites mesures
techniques qui sont pas totalement
inintéressant c'est un texte extrêmement
creux qui ne changera rien au problème
qui dure à avoir les mêmes problèmes
qu'on a attrapé au bureau mais le
gouvernement aura fait beaucoup de qom
pendant plusieurs mois pour faire croire
aux français que les arrivées ce
problème avec la question écologique
seagate de moi même on a un projet de
loi qui doit faire semblant de régler le
problème et dans le même temps on
cherche des centrales nucléaires ce qui
aggrave immédiatement nos la
consommation de 2,2 de carbone fois donc
c'est tout ça n'est que de la
communication
pour barbara pompe il est ministre de
l'écologie il faut faire du vélo comme
on va acheter son pain ça c'était là a
déclaré dans les colonnes du jdd
dimanche dernier vous partagez cette
vision l'écologie
écoutez je ne sont pas venus à pied ou
en vélo oui m'enfin ça montre bien à
quel point c'est quelque chose quand
même avec des besoins de prendre une loi
au tueur aux gens d'aller chercher
d'éviter de formation pour aller
chercher dans un donc sur nrj société
très totalitaire rires ça dans la loi
enfin soit le toit mans de la proche du
travail parlementaire qui ne sert à rien
enfin tout ça tout ça n'est pas sérieux
ça n'est pas à la hauteur et je dis une
fois encore dans le même temps le charme
centrales nucléaires qu'elle stagne ce
qui est unique et on nous oblige à
importer de l'électricité produite comme
allemagne à base de charbon donc où est
la cohérence
où est la cohérence ce gouvernement
gouverne par une succession de messages
de communication
destiné à chaque fois à une cible
électorale donc une fois c'est les gens
qui sont préoccupées par la dégradation
de l'unité nationale seulement qu'on
puisse dire dans certains de nos
quartiers de la montée de deux des dix
kahnisme une autre fois c'est un message
envoyé aux écologistes
voilà c'est une succession de petits
éléments de communication c'est pas ça
qui fait qui fait une politique est qui
et qui réellement en mettra sur les
rails
en tout cas la france traverse ces jours
ci une période de grand froid un danger
pour les personnes en situation de
précarité une précarité et qui
ad'ailleurs grandi avec la crise
sanitaire
hier le premier ministre a répondu sur
le sujet une question de jean luc
mélenchon regarder le froid monsieur le
premier ministre vous vous en doutez est
aussi une calamité sociale les pauvres
gens vont souffrir davantage encore il y
a dans notre pays trois cent mille
personnes sans domicile fixe dont trente
mille enfants le froid glaciaire sera
sans pitié à leur égard
monsieur le premier ministre que comptez
vous faire pour eux ce gouvernement
cette majorité ne sont pas restés
inactifs face à cette situation
et face à ces situations dramatiques
la campagne hivernale puisque c'était le
début de votre question a commencé le 17
octobre dernier et cela soyons très
précis pour la représentation nationale
nous a conduit à ouvrir depuis 17
octobre
vingt mille places supplémentaires pour
les sans abri portant leur nombre à 200
milles ce qui constitue un record alors
vingt mille places supplémentaires pour
les sans abri le premier ministre parle
d'un engagement inédit pour la lutte
contre la précarité
le gouvernement fait il assez sûrs ou
alors non il fait passer pour une simple
raison c'est que ce qu'oublie de dire le
premier ministre aussi que le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile dans leur pays a été
multiplié par trois et qu'en réalité
depuis que depuis que macro est au
pouvoir on a une explosion de la demande
d'asile est donc en réalité toutes les
places dans les foyers
d'hébergement d'urgence sont aujourd'hui
monopolisé le parent de demandeurs
d'asile qui prennent du coup la place un
certain nombre de nos deux compatriotes
qui se retrouvent en difficulté parce
que c'est un moment je notamment les
autres associations de rupture familiale
brutale et qui ont besoin d'un
déplacement de lens 2 n'en trouvent pas
aujourd'hui à cause de ce phénomène
donc voilà ce que ce don sinon je sais
qu est avec ses hobbies de parler c'est
ça et dire c'est super manche envie de
parler c'est ça aussi il ya un petit que
l'on peut pas à la fois je plains
n'était pas assez de place pour les
français que des français dorment dans
la rue et en même temps encourager comme
je fais aussi l'extrême gauche une
immigration totalement incontrôlée dans
notre pays va ce qui est terrible c'est
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement c'est la
conjonction de deux phénomènes
on ne peut pas le garantir que les
français ne dormiront pas dans la rue y
compris dans cet épisode de grand froid
alors dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire la commission européenne a
voté hier un plan de relance européen et
les équipes d'ursula von der leyen ont
rappelé une exigence à les gouvernements
doivent prévoir des réformes
structurelles celle de la france au
comprenait notamment une réforme des
retraites
cette exigence de l'europe vous la
comprenez elle vous paraît adaptée
ecoutez-la lupin total elle et elle est
à la fois scandaleuse mais pas
surprenante
c'est le pas sur le pacte faustien qu'un
signé emmanuel macron je pense qu'on
n'avait pas besoin de ce prêt de
l'europe on n'a pas cette mobilisation
forcément de l'europe
en réalité pour en matière de dette mais
là de la dette c'est finalement de la
seule réponse que connaît quelques-uns
emmanuel macron en cela ils montrent
qu'il est bien le successeur de françois
hollande
donc on est allé chercher la dette
européenne d'être on va payer très cher
puisque l'europe nous prêtent 40
milliards on devra rembourser un peu
plus de 60 milliards puisqu'on a choisi
c'est en fait d'appliquer dès les clés
budgétaire habituel de l'europe donc on
sera alors c'est d'emprunt et donc on
aurait pu s'en extraire on aurait pu
monter l'europe dont on sait que 40
milliards viennent
va rembourser plus tôt que ça c'était
déjà une première mauvaise nouvelle est
la deuxième mauvaise nouvelle qui pas
complètement une surprise c'est que
l'europe puisqu'on lui à la commission
européenne puisqu'elle s'est fait un peu
exporter cette cette dette commune dans
cet isolement n'était pas n'étaient pas
favorables rapport aux 6 à faire
habituellement c'est à dire des réformes
des réformes structurelles c'est
évidemment pas l'europe de nous donner
des leçons et de mettre des pays des
pays sous tutelle d'avoir ce type de
conditionnement au passage j'observe
quand même de manière un peu amusé que
sa démarche aussi un peu le président de
la république qui en réalité a beaucoup
parlé de réformes depuis quatre ans mais
finalement on n'a pas été capable d'en
faire un poussière beaucoup notamment la
réforme des retraites qui était une
mauvaise réforme de de mon point de vue
telle qu'elle était conçue mais qu'il a
dû abandonner en rase campagne
merci beaucoup olivier marvex d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin sur rtl
france je le rappelle vous êtes député
les républicains d'eure-et-loir